*Réveil*
*Tape le réveil pour stopper sa sonnerie*
Pfff
*Main*
*Musique épic*
*Gémissement chelou de Norman*
*Gémissement vraiment chelou de Norman*
*Musique épic*
*Gémissement chelou de Norman*
*Fais tomber de yaourt Velouté à l'abricot*
*Musique épic*
*Moto*
*Cet homme est dégueulasse*
*Musique épic*
*Musique égyptienne ou arabe*
L'ami d'Adjib : Adjib !
*Tu te d'emmerdes !*
*Musique égyptienne ou arabe*
L'ami d'Adjib : Lul
*Musique épic*
*Mme Pavoshko entrain de crever*
*Gémissement chelou de Norman, le retour*
*Musique épic*
*Viole de musique épic*
Norman : Waaw *essoufflé*
*respirationù
Norman : Promotion sur la jambon à Carrefour ?
*respiration*
Norman : Haha !
*Musique....*
*Guitare*